why do you still come to the gym you
know 75 years old I mean you you you did
the Mr Universe well for the same reason
you know we talked about that for the
same reason as why am I having breakfast
today I had breakfast yesterday had
breakfast 10 years ago why am I still
having breakfast right it's like it's
part of your day why am I still sleeping
I slept 20 years ago I slept 10 years
ago so I'm still sleeping every night so
it's so rooted in who you are exactly
say the same is with training training
is part of my life it's that simple
nothing will ever change until I die I
will be working out and I will be having
a great time in the gym and I will be
getting the pump and I I and I want to
feel good